so I'm somewhat privileged position
because we as a novelist don't just get
to inhabit our own subjectivity but
other substitue knees and I can't begin
to tell you how powerful and weird this
is when you're creating a character you
are it's all different you if it's adult
so I and I find it a useful way of
making discoveries and in fact one of
the discoveries I've made has been
adopted in certain branches of
psychology and it was a discovery in me
when I was writing my very first book my
body problem and my editor said to me
when he read the first draft you know
this woman is beautiful she's very very
smart she's got everything and she's so
miserable she is so unhappy why is she
so unhappy and I thought about that if
she was very unhappy you know I could
tell because somehow or other we were
merged not that was autobiographical and
and I thought well if she doesn't feel
like she matters um she's got she's got
that so that the and to me that was some
of your very memory Tori that underneath
this idea of flourishing it seems to me
is this idea of of mattering of of you
know and then I came to this idea and
this is
been adopted by certain branches of
psychology it's a theoretical constant
looking from a novel of a different
manner the mattering map with different
zones of mattering and you know it in
her world being they're very smart
matter the great deal and you know other
world you know dressing well matters a
great deal they're all different
mattering zones in if you inhabit
imagining zone in which you're you don't
matter or your mattering is it in doubt
um you're you're not sloshing you're
just not flourishing and that seems to
me an interesting meaning it also to me
shed light on the question that I often
get and I think all of us get here those
of us who have come out as atheist how
does your have any median I think oh man
I don't even understand and it was that
there was a way in which it was assured
under the monotheistic paradigm that we
that we all mattered you know we're made
in the image of God we matter we're
being judged and everything we do it's
kind of terrifying because there's this
cosmic approval and disapproval that
you're bathed in constantly but you sure
as hell matter and and that that's
that's removed now and on a secular in a
secular world in a naturalist world I
mean you don't get that that kind of
assurance I kind of this is a guarantee
of mattering I think that's very
important
are often challenged on this score and
with it with a very important point
people say well look at your lives you
have so many reasons to be gratified
you've had great adventures great
success you know but most people can't
live lives like that and what about the
lives of everybody else the fact that
you don't need religion big deal and I
think in fact this problem now gets sort
of worse around the world because of the
information age and people see in on
television and in movies and everywhere
they see they see heroic lives they see
lives that matter they see lives that
have meaning and whether it's it's the
police procedural whether it's the
clever detective that saves the life of
somebody or whether you know and there's
religion saying you want to matter we
can make you matter join our army become
onward Christian soldiers and it's an
extremely tempting offer and there you
are you're you know you're pumping gas
at the crossroads and wondering what the
heck your life's all about and if
somebody comes along and suggests that
your life could have drama
it could have significance that you
could be a sort of hero
Wow jump at it and I think what we have
to do as naturalist
is really work positively to think of
secular projects secular campaigns
secular communities secular
organizations that will give people ways
of mattering if they don't already have
them and that's something that religion
does I'm afraid very well
and we should try to replace it we
really should make it one of our goals
to find secular alternatives to Crusades
because we're creating God's image with
her hat and I also love the you know
just the word mattering is very crucial
here that mattering to other people and
it goes along with Aristotle's idea that
happened we all want to have friends a
very plausible basis for why we have
meaning in our lives as secularists and
yet the evolution of a secular society
has decreased the opportunities for this
kind of social interaction that makes us
matter and helps us matter and I don't
you know I'd be happy to endorse the
call for organizations and so forth
I'm very unclear how to make that happen
in reality as a programmatic matter you
know how to have an organization that in
a secular context plays that role that
the community building role that
religion had he was at this conference
Jeffrey's axis place at Columbia and he
wrote this book called Bowling Alone
which I haven't read but it's a very
compelling title of this maybe the state
of the American community and he was
interesting at this conference because I
had heard for that--hey I'd heard it
reported that he was one of these guys
who says that going to church
almost all measures is better for
people's well-being this is related to
Dan's point but at this particular
conference he said now that they've
served called all the data it has
nothing to do with belief in anything it
just has to do with it you're not
Bowling Alone and this is exactly Dan's
point this is the crucial point it is
very Aristotelian about needing ways to
have secular communities
you